sorry 59 evacuation orders
in place affecting 40 000
people
in relation to evacuation warnings we
have 15 evacuation warnings in place
affecting 20 000 people
we also know
that there is a pending
evacuation order coming for many people
as a result of the manly dam beginning
to spill that will affect 800 homes
and 2 000 people if there is an
evacuation warning in place
please get ready to leave if there is an
evacuation order in place
please evacuate please follow the
instructions of our state and emergency
services they are there to keep you and
your family safe
at this difficult time and as we move
through the week
we will continue to see instances
of flash flooding so it will continue
the rain on the central coast illawarra
and and sydney area tonight then ease as
we get into the early hours of tomorrow
morning and then finally drag all the
rainfall off our east coast as we get
into tomorrow afternoon with just a few
showers remaining the other concern
though is as we move into tonight winds
are rapidly increasing along parts of
the illawarra and sydney metropolitan
area the sydney airport is gusting to 60
kilometers an hour guatemala is gusting
up to 80 kilometers an hour and we
expect those winds to increase and
strengthen further tonight as the low
rapidly deepens offshore now this is
obviously not great news
i think what's happening in or i know
what's happening in this event is people
make decisions based on past history
and i think this event has shown that
this is there is no past history similar
to this event the danger still continues
this afternoon if anyone who's out on
the roads are out at the moment there is
intense heavy rainfalls as we speak um
and it doesn't take much to flow into
the rivers
it's not soaking into the ground the
ground is saturated
and there's every likelihood that the
rivers may rise again as the day goes on
a tough 24 hours or even 48 hours ahead
and even if the rain does stop on
wednesday and thursday which it will
there's still a lot of water in these
rivers